in this video I want it's like a little
bit about naming nucleotides and
nucleosides sometimes they can get a
little bit tricky so I kind of want to
go over it briefly that way in case I
reference them at any point later on
that it makes sense
so if we have nucleus sides right we
charge is just a pentose sugar with some
nitrogenous base well these are the
nitrogenous bases here so if they're
attached to a ribose they would be
nucleosides in the case of adenine being
the base if it was ribose plus adenine
it would be called a denno scene okay
now if it was ribose and the guanine it
would be guano seen so the two purines
adenine and guanine are named similarly
you basically just added an OC n-- okay
in the case of uracil and cytosine which
are both per immanence they become your
Adeem right sounds like pyrimidine and
site to Dean right this is a ribose with
a uracil attached to it and this is a
ribose with a cytosine attached to it
they'd become Yura Dean and cited
respectively now what if you have I mean
notice I've written in yellow and I put
a pink star next to it so now if I mean
attached to a deoxyribose would be cyma
Dean and find me doesn't attach to
ribose because thymine is only in DNA
right so if you recall DNA having AST
season G's and RNA having a is used
season G's thymine is only in DNA so it
could only be a deoxy nucleoside so it
is called thymidine okay but more
specifically or precisely it's deoxy
thymidine and that's but that's
it always had the deoxy it's only in DNA
right so that's what I want to right
here right Simon is only deoxy so it's
because it's only in DNA not RNA so for
all of these other ones here
all of these other nucleotides these are
ribonucleotides on their identity and
wanna senior 18 inside a Dean they can
also if you want to make these deoxy if
the sugar is instead of ribose it's
deoxyribose all you have to do these
names is put a deoxy in front of them as
a prefix so this would be deoxyadenosine
or deoxy guanosine deoxy or a Dean deoxy
cited date now fly me Dean is Lima Dean
and the academic dean are the same thing
which is why I feel like more
comfortable just calling it deoxy time'
Dean because this saying this Lima Dean
is kind of confusing and maybe
misleading so keep that in mind now what
if we have nucleotides well if you
recall I mentioned in the previous video
that nucleotides are just nucleoside
phosphates so they're just a nucleoside
with phosphate groups attached to them
and I said that you could add 1 2 or 3
phosphates to the 5 prime carbon of the
sugar so in the case of nucleotides you
basically just give it the nucleoside
name and then put a 5 prime and then the
blank here and then a phosphate now what
can go in this blank well that depends
on the number of phosphates so if you
had adenine attached to ribose and you
had one phosphate group at the 5 prime n
it would be adenosine for the name for
the nucleoside and then if it only had
one phosphate at the 5 prime end it
would be called mono phosphate if I had
two it would be diphosphate so identity
in five prime diphosphate or adenosine
five prime triphosphate if there are
three phosphates so it's the same thing
for these other ones here you just give
it a nucleated in the nucleoside name
and then five prime and then however
many phosphates there are right so with
thymidine you don't give it that name
right you would only give it the deoxy
name so it would be
oxi thymidine five prime and then
however many phosphates again because
you would not find this in RNA it's an
old it's not a ribonucleotide it's a
deoxyribonucleotide only okay so now
that we've gone over these names let's
kind of put this in into perspective by
talking about a few examples so if you
were asked to draw a DA MP which is
deoxy adenosine monophosphate right or
it's more specifically deoxyadenosine 5
prime mono phosphate so the deoxy the
deoxy means that you're going to have
your sugars and the VD oxy ribose and we
know that because of this here right
this 2 prime carbon on the ribose sugar
has no Oh H group has just the age group
so that's the deoxy now at the 1 prime
carbon we have the base and in this case
it's editing because it's called
adenosine so this adenine is attached
here at this nitrogen and then at the 5
prime carbon right up here we have we
should have one phosphate group so I've
drawn one phosphate group so this was
deoxy adenosine 5 prime mono phosphate
now what if you're asked to draw UTP
which is your Adeem 5 prime triphosphate
well so there's no deoxy so we would
expect the ribose right so that's why we
have this o H here instead of an H at
the two prime carbon and then of course
it's your a diene so we've the the
nitrogenous base attached to the 1 prime
carbon should be uracil that's what we
have here and at the 5 prime n we should
have 3 phosphate groups so there's 1 2 3
phosphate groups
so that's UTP now what about guanosine
well guanosine is just a nucleoside
right so up here these were both
nucleotides ones just this is a
ribonucleotide up here this is a
deoxyribonucleotide so now here we just
have a nucleoside so there's no
phosphate groups
so in guanosine this is not deoxy so
here we have an O H instead of an just
an H and at the 1 prime carbon of the
ribose we should have a guanine
nitrogenous base and that's what we have
here if we get attached at the correct
nitrogen in the case of deoxy cited Dean
well deoxy right so we have the H there
at the two prime carbon the office
excited eating there's no phosphates
right this is a new Clio to me a
ribonucleoside and ch2oh over here right
cuz there's no phosphate groups and then
cited e means that the the nitrogenous
base was cytosine which is what we have
here alright that's pretty much it I
hope that was helpful in a sort of
overview kind of way that's a bit that's
it I hope you find that helpful
one last thing I am a tutor if you live
in Southern California feel free to
contact me via email and check out the
description for more details thanks for
watching